Snarky chat. Snarky chat.
The skulls. The skulls. The skulls.
Ethan, we don't care about the skulls
anymore. Okay. Oh, he's Oh my god. No
way. No way. That guy just said that,
dude. Take responsibility for your
mistakes. Act like a man. Stop being a
whiny. How hard is this? Why don't you
want to attach yourself, Ethan? It
>> Why don't you want to say who sent us
this information? Eton.
Okay. Should we start on Ethan Klein?
Let's see. I'm squashing the beef with
Idubbbz H3 show. So, H3 is going to go
and not fight with Idubbbz anymore,
apparently. All right. Apparently, this
was yesterday. We didn't get a chance to
cover it yesterday.
And there's some funny stuff in here.
Okay. This funny stuff. He ends up going
over the Dioro tweet like Nicholas Yoro
responding to him and that'll be funny
as well. Okay. There's a lot of coping
there. Let's go.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
>> All right. So,
excuse me. As the title thumbnail
suggests, I will be talking about Ian
and Ana. There has been an embargo and
it and it and I'll tell you like the oil
embargo um of that hit Japan
pre Pearl Harbor it hurt it is hurting
them
right
they they their numbers are anemic
the the members it's down it's basically
almost about to go below 400
like the most loser version of PPP this
is like PPP PP PPP on Xanax. Okay, this
is like Xanax PPP.
Hold on. How How would PPP do this?
>> They they their numbers are anemic.
>> Their numbers are anemic.
>> The the members it's down. It's
basically almost about to go below 400.
>> THEIR MEMBERSHIP IS BELOW 400,
>> RIGHT? The viewership is in the what two
300s.
NOBODY WATCHES THEM, YOU KNOW? LIKE, why
don't put some energy in, man? Put some
energy and effort in, dude.
>> Very different show with Nate on the
soundboard. I got to be
>> I do like I'm watching a Tik Tok.
>> I like, by the way, I can't even match
it now, man.
>> Quit out of embarrassment. She started
streaming and she's like, "Yeah, I'm
building a fan base." I'm like, "Uh,
Ian, this is the best. I'm so good at
this." to all of a sudden flash forward.
She can't even hold 80 live viewers. And
now she's like, "Actually, I'm too busy
for this. You're busy. You don't have a
job. You don't have kids. You're not
busy. You're a loser. Excuse me."
>> Dude, this is so sad, man. This is so
sad.
>> How the are you going to tell me?
>> This is why we have to squash beefs with
like random people. Okay. You can't you
can't ever become Ethan Klein. You just
got to like let stuff go. If you carry
stuff for so long, it just starts to
corrode your soul, right? You just got
to let it go. You just got to
let it go. It's gone. We don't care
anymore. It's fine. I mean, you're busy
if you don't even have a job or kids.
You should How?
Busy doing what exactly? Serving an
uncut bagel on a paper plate.
>> Wow.
>> How exactly are you spending your time?
But anyway,
>> good one, Ethan.
>> I'm a big fan if you can't tell.
But at any rate, I am breaking the
embargo,
but it's for one last time.
Um, and I I
this is it. Like, I'm out.
And
you know, I broke the embargo recently
because uh Ian issued an apology to me
and my family
>> for platforming the um let's say
the silly light-hearted joke.
>> Oh my god, dude. This is Yeah. Yeah. I'm
just going to play it now. We can just
watch it now.
>> Yeah. This is
>> This is unironically posted, I believe,
to the H3H3 subreddit. I thought it was
photoshopped or I thought it was edited
somehow. I thought it was AI. I didn't
want to believe that it existed. To be
honest, this is like I watch this and
I'm like, "Dude, let the tech
billionaires win. Let's see what they
can do with humanity." We We did fail.
We need transhumanism. Let the tech
billionaires win. Make us eat bugs.
Actually, humanity was a mistake.
>> Yeah. Hold down a job.
>> Listen to this. The dude is unemployed.
>> He's ugly.
I value you.
>> He can't eat the dude.
>> Never been able to work.
>> On the bills.
>> You're better off with it. You're
honestly better off alone. But guess
what? A better man is just around the
corner.
>> Oh my god.
>> This can't be real. I do believe it's
real. I I dude, I do believe it's real.
People are saying it's real. I'm being
I'm being informed it's real. video
activates some deep-seated Mongolian
conquest instinct within my stomach.
Jesus Christ, Kilo. Jesus Christ, Kilo.
Caption says, "Everything I have to
say."
But and then I saw people being like,
"Okay, honestly,
this is development. Ian is is actually
maybe he's um he's come along. Maybe
he's actually developing as a
character." But I was the only one that
knew. No, it happened like one day after
we sent them a cease and desist, they
stopped talking about us,
>> right? So, I know why they stopped and I
know we have a really good case in
Canada and their lawyer told them that,
right? And so, essentially that's what
it is. But uh so Ian and Ana reacted to
my uh response to them which was um
basically just saying that I sent them a
cease and assist.
>> We got a cease and desist. And obviously
that you know I I was being um genuine
uh in my apology cuz I I was reflecting.
>> Yeah. Yeah. He was being genuine. It
just so happened to coincide
with the immediately receiving a cease
and assist. Not the fact that you like
spend your whole day in with and in and
supporting and calling shouting out a
community whose logo is a skull with a
CPS written across it.
>> Oh,
what's that reference, guys? Who's he
Who could he possibly Who could he
possibly be talking about? Who would do
that? Who could do that? Who would do
such a thing? A skull with CPS written
on it. Who would do such a thing? That's
crazy. Okay, that's totally crazy.
>> You thought that was funny and awesome
and cool, right? Until the moment you
got a cease and assist. You had a you
you had a moment of clarity and then you
got a cease and assist right afterwards
and and then you really meant it.
>> Cool. And um I think it was out of out
of line for my own personal is Idubbbz
in the Jtock Kiwi Farms Pisco Hassan
Cabal now. Yes, that is what Ethan is
saying. Yes, that is what he's saying.
>> I guess goals in life and like how I
wants to be,
>> right?
>> Um and I think ultimately even after my
apology, he still doesn't seem to be to
think that it's real or genuine.
>> Yeah. Why? Why? Uh yeah, you're right,
man.
Why I should I should take it as the way
it was meant to be. Just completely
sincere. Like if he, you know,
unironically, if he had issued this type
of apology like
I don't know, months ago, I would have
thought it was sincere.
But to do it like right after you get a
cease and desist, how can I like I'm I'm
not even being this to be like snarky.
I'm being like, how am I actually
supposed to think it's sincere? If I
thought it was sincere, I would like,
you know, my I would have a my heart
would soften. You know, I I'm the first
person to let a grudge go when I'm
apologized. All you have to say is I'm
funny. Right, Dan? You know that
>> he's not actually joking about that.
That That is true.
>> I'm so quick to forgive.
>> He's quick to anger, but quick to
forgive.
>> To a fault, I would say even
>> huge fault. Probably one of the biggest
biggest I've ever seen on any person.
>> See Dan. Yeah, Dan.
>> Dude, is that That's like the Yeah,
that's the show now is they like subtly
try to just rain Ethan in. Try to keep
it on the rails. Can we just keep this
on the rails, man? We got another year
and a half of of milking these morons in
our audience dry before this runs out.
Could you just keep us on track? I need
this job for at least another year and a
half. Okay.
>> Understands me and he should after all
these years. Yeah.
>> Listen, I don't I don't watch the
podcast. In fact, it gives me an
aneurysm and it like distresses me
greatly to watch it. So, I I only hear
it through the
>> You just catch clips of it on your snark
subreddit. Those ones don't upset you.
>> Yeah. I only like watching the worst
clips that are upsetting.
>> Mhm. The ones that are curated
explicitly to upset me. Those ones are
terrible. But I I'm on that subreddit
all day every day. And I'm not even
being like hyperbolic.
You rolled out this Scorch Legume
character for the express purpose of
browsing Snark,
>> which is a shame that he tied that
branding to this because now he can't
continue the character. And it was
>> that he tied that to sorry he
just to browse snark like you do to do
segments on them like they weren't doing
before you started on them like it's
just such a it's such a comedy of errors
like there's no reason he should have
ever gone after Idubbbz and anise in the
first place. He just had no reason to
right. I think he did it purely because
they're kind of cringe and he just
wanted a good enemy to have. I don't
really think there was any reason to go
after them. They were just being silent.
They're just sitting in their corner. I
understand that if you think they're
your friends, it feels wrong for them to
sit in the corner over there, okay, and
not do anything. But it's just so It's
so weird, man. It's so weird now. It
>> was so It was so funny that it's just
such a shame,
>> you know?
It it it is right.
>> Did Dan just imply that was so funny?
>> There's like a
snarky chat. Snarky chat.
Uh,
bro, this is crazy. The shout outs go
hard, man.
This is totally wild. I don't know why
they
Why do they Man, I am Am I crazy? They
just make us seem so cool. They make us
seem like terrorists and then like these
guys are unemployed. These guys are so
so mean and unemployed and evil. Like,
dude, can you not [__] on somebody and
hold down a job? I can. I've done it. I
participate in these communities online.
I was in something of a snark community
when I was employed full-time making
Well, to the six figures, okay? I was in
a smart community. It was DG, by the
way. But I was in a Stark community. All
right. It's very easy to be in a Stark
community that watches streams a lot and
comments on them and sh on people. It's
very easy to do that and be employed at
the same time.
these like yeah just total lack of
ambition total lack of drive people they
have no passion you're passionate about
something you make time for it all right
we're passionate about this chatter of
this like secret discord of like crazy
Twitter uh Reddit political snarkers
like these high level
>> crazy Reddit Twitter political snarkers
and by the way he's going to talk about
I think the grill pill people is who
talking about, right? I don't I like
unless somebody's in there on an alt and
I'm unaware of it.
It's I don't think a single one of those
grill pill Jake Chinatown people is in
there. He's that's who's going to blame
this
>> reply guys.
It's all starting to come out. I don't
>> the highle reply guys.
>> Well, you know, like the the Jake
Chinatowns and all these characters.
>> Ah, yeah. Yeah.
>> The bad.
>> I'm just I'm I'm listen I'm distancing
from Jake Chinatown. Not on any moral
grounds. on like I don't even know what
his Twitter's about to be honest with
you. I know he's like a pro-Hassan like
anti- what's a Twitter community. I know
he like posts he's like a leftyish or
whatever, right? But I don't know that
much about him. I'm only distancing cuz
I do not want Flesh Simulator to dox me.
Okay, Flesh Simulator, stop. Stop. I'm
not I'm not involved. Okay,
that's I know that they've got beef with
the Flesh Simulator guy. Okay, that's
what I know.
It's all starting to come out. The high
level reply guys.
>> Well, you know, like the the Jake
Chinatowns and all these characters.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> The bad empanadas and you know all these
regular who say the worst possible
things and then they're re uh retweeted
by Hassan like once or twice a month to
feed the machine. This is the whole
thing. This is how Hassan This is the
insane coordination. When Hassan sees
somebody on somebody he doesn't like and
retweets it. That's insane coordination,
guys. That's insane coordination. It
couldn't be that we're just total scum.
It couldn't be that we're just like some
of the worst human beings going on the
entirety of YouTube. It couldn't be
that. It just has to be that Hassan is
coordinating all of it. It couldn't be
us. It couldn't be me and my total
psychopathy towards all these people. It
It has to be them. It has to be Hassan.
The only The only way people don't like
me is Hassan.
No, Ethan. We just watch you. We just
see you. We just see you. We don't like
you.
Ed Hassan likes something funny. Yeah.
Yeah. It's just sad, man. This is goofy.
>> Mhm.
>> So, somebody leaked is has somehow got
this entire log over the past year and a
half and I haven't seen the messages,
but I have seen the name and look.
>> So, why would he say that? Oh, someone
got this. Someone got this, guys. I
don't know who, but like someone got it.
Like, someone somewhere got it.
Why don't you Hey, Ethan, why don't you
want to say
who's telling you about this? Why don't
you want to say who did get the leak?
Why don't you want to attach yourself?
Ethan. Itan. Hey, why don't you want to
say who sent us this information? Anon,
can anybody tell me? Oh, cuz it's
destiny. And you want to act like you
aren't this dude's.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
And I haven't seen the messages, but I
have seen the name and logo for this
snark community. And I mean, they wear
it like a badge of honor, right? That
CPS came to my house, that human skulls
were sent to my house. Two of them. And
I mean, the these are the groups of
people you've spent the last year
aligning with. Ah, the skulls. The
skulls. The skulls. Ethan, we don't care
about the skulls anymore, okay? We joke
about the skulls now. We don't care
about the skulls. You got You got like a
total You got like a year and a half of
psychopathy off of the skulls. No more.
We're done with the skulls now. Okay.
Yeah. Like your full year and a half in
year and a half. Well, hold on. Full
year. Full year of psychopathy. We don't
care about the skulls anymore, man.
We're done. It's We're good. We don't
need any more of that.
>> Right.
And you know, listen,
I just I just it's hard for me to feel
bad. It is. It is
>> right. Fine. I have to, you know, to use
a little bit of a therapy term. I have
to protect my peace. So, I don't know
what any details are, but I think in
summary, it look
>> take a vow of celibacy and go to a
monastery. I don't know what to tell
you. So, there's no peace to be had
here.
>> I just need to protect you my peace.
>> You I just need to protect like my
peace. Okay.
>> You sacrificed that piece to the altar
of clout when you made that content cop
about me,
>> right?
>> How long ago was that again now?
>> Over a year.
>> It was like around Was it around time
last year?
>> About a year.
>> I don't I don't want to be that guy.
I don't want to be the guy that's suing
people that's like, you know.
>> Yes, you do. You want to be the guy
that's loved, but nothing about how you
act makes you loved. So, you're doing
the next best thing. What do you mean? I
don't want to be I just want everybody
to love me, but I'll take suing them
into loving me if that's if that fails.
Okay. Okay.
>> Obsessively just on you no matter how
minute and ridiculous it is forever all
the time.
>> Isn't that your brand kind of
>> dude? What? Oh, he's Oh my god. No way.
No way. That guy just said that, dude.
Dude, what?
Wow. Wow. Dude, I got to watch it again.
Back further. Back.
>> You sacrificed that piece to the altar
of clout when you made that content cop
about me, right?
>> How long ago was that again now? Over a
year.
>> Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. This is
like This is why you got to let stuff
go, man. All your friends just be like,
"Dude, that was so long ago, man." Are
you seriously still on about this? How
long ago was that? It was a year ago.
Oh, it was over a year ago. Oh, and
you're still ass pained about it? Yeah.
Okay. All right. Whatever you say,
Ethan.
>> It was like around Was it around time
last year?
>> About a year.
>> I don't I don't want to be that guy.
>> I don't want to be the guy that's suing
people that's like,
>> you know, obsessively just on you no
matter how minute and ridiculous it is
forever all the time.
>> Isn't that your brand?
>> About that.
>> I don't want to be that guy though, you
know? And but ultimately
when
>> dude that just rolls off him too. Oh no.
He was stands broken for like a
millisecond. He's just like I don't want
to be that guy. No, I don't want I don't
want that.
>> When you do what you did when you put
out that video when I was live when you
when you
encouraged and applauded the CPS visits
you justified.
>> Didn't encourage and applaud the CPS
visits. Are you Why are you so insanely
stealth victimizing? Like what? What
the? Show me. Someone show me. Someone
show me anywhere.
What the What are we even talking about,
man? What are we talking about, dude?
>> Blaine, I know people who watch the show
understand the we've been dealing with
since all this stuff, but it's hard to
understand. Like,
>> this is a group of 50 people that have
spent all day and night, 24 hours a day
unemployed.
dedicated to ruining mine and many other
people few other people's lives.
>> No. Nope. I understand that
accountability might look that way to
somebody who's led a really life and
made millions of dollars doing it, but
no. Nobody wants to ruin your life. You
could ride off into the literally just
stop abusing people. Literally, just
stop being a total piece of just stop
right now. You escape everything. You
don't even have to do anything, dude.
You are independently wealthy. You don't
have to BE HERE. YOU CAN'T OPT in to
being a total You can't be a total piece
of and opt into public commentary and
then go, "These guys are really mean.
These guys are really, really mean. Shut
up."
So, it's so stupid, man.
>> But this is like specifically like,
"Yeah, the clients." And you've
encouraged them.
>> You're so mean to me.
>> You've you've endorsed them, man. You've
called them great people. You've sent
people there. And right up until the day
before you got that cease and desist,
you were applauding them, right? And
just suddenly had a change of heart. So
I apologize for not taking your apology
sincerely. I do. You know, I've had
little reason to.
>> Is your apology sincere or is this an
insincere apology to
>> dude? It's rough. I have a little I have
a little bit of empathy for Ethan Klein
because he's like listen he's got people
around him who want to retain his human
who want him to retain his humanity. I
get it. He wants to be like a demon but
they're like no. Hey Ethan, you should
be nice.
>> Sorry. I'm sorry. I guess in a I'm sorry
that I don't believe it. I don't know if
that's I don't know what that means. I
wish I could believe it was sincere.
>> Dan does see what's going on. Dan Dan
sees everything. that would actually
make me feel
like um like good like that.
>> I dude, can we be that far away from Dan
leaving the show? I feel like Dan is
he's very obviously understanding like
he gets it. He sees what's going on.
Also, it's not as bad. It's not as bad.
But he he sees what's going on and how
far away could we possibly be from from
him possibly leaving or something? I
don't know.
>> Was you know some peace to be had?
>> Too well paid maybe. But how can I see
it as sincere given the circumstance?
You know,
>> looks like he he's interested, Ethan, in
pursuing a lawsuit here in Canada. Um, I
ultimately am just like not interested
in like playing that game.
>> Yeah, that's funny. Of course you're
not. He's like, I don't want to get
sued, so I'm not going to. But that's
not how it works. Of course,
>> dude. It's so cowardly to like have the
the idea of a lawsuit hanging over these
people's heads and you're like just on
them just like, "Well, I guess you guys
you guys like reacted to something I
said." And you know what?
Not smart with a lawsuit. I'm going to
sue you. I'm I'm ready to sue you, dude.
Even if he hasn't sued them, even if
he's like not serious about it, the the
idea of it now is a cudgel in and of
itself. And he's just a total piece of
[__] He's just total scum for doing
this. Well, I'm going to talk about you
and if you talk back, I'm going to sue
you.
>> I, you know, and I don't want to sue
you, right? I I don't want to do all
this. But
>> Yes, you do. Yes, you do. Yes, you do.
This is not outside of your control. You
are an adult. Stop acting like such a
whiny. You are a man. Act like a man.
How difficult is it?
You say the things that you say and you
bring consequences. You don't like Oh my
god. I I When you talk about your
family's health situation on a stream,
you are not protecting your family. That
is not what a a protector does. Act like
a man, Ethan Klein. Take responsibility
for your mistakes. Act like a man. Stop
being a whiny. How hard is this?
>> At the end of the day, I have made a
commitment and I am
the ultimate hater. And that's not even
an opinion.
>> No man, let me tell you, the ultimate
haters are in that are in that CPS Skull
Discord, okay? That's where the ultimate
haters are. You don't know, bro. You are
doing this cuz you're rich and it cost
you nothing. Could you imagine the kind
of people who want to do the same [__]
Who want to like go and follow somebody
all the time, follow all of their
content, watch every hour of their
stream? They're just doing it for the
love of the [__] game. Can you
imagine Ethan Klein? Can you imagine
people just doing it for the love of the
game? They're not They're not rich. They
don't pay somebody else to look up the
timestamps. They watch. They search,
right? They they do transcript searches.
They do all these things just just
because they think you're a bad person
and somebody should watch that clip of
you being a bad person and laugh at you.
>> But I do truly believe that do when Dr.
Mike gave Ian brain damage, that's when
he became anti-semitic.
>> Oh, it's all anti-semitism. It's all
anti-semitism in Hassan, guys.
>> I really truly do believe that. But the
last thing this guy needs, man, is more
sand in his gears. You know, please
don't fight.
>> Maybe it'll fix things, you know? It's
like when you hit a controller,
eventually it works. I have found that
to occasionally be helpful
>> to smack a computer or something. It
does fix it sometimes.
>> It could knock the anti-semitism out of
them.
>> Why? Why do this? Why go live and just
do this like weird neuroticism calling
this guy anti-semitic? What has he said
or done that's anti-semitic? Like
anything at all.
The sword is is the sword. We're going
to do the sword. It was I guess it's
just the sword, guys.
>> Who would have to hit him in the head to
do that? I don't know. Look it up.
Google it.
>> As much as I don't like Ian, I don't
want to see him like in a even worse
state, right? Nobody deserves that. I
mean, listen, if you do another fight,
who's to say? Why are you trying to
cope? Trying to destroy his life. Don't
cope. This is the thing. This is the
most despicable duplicitous in my
opinion.
If you want to go demon time, you want
to be that guy. you want to be the guy
who destroys these people, then be that
guy, but actually do it. Don't do this
halfway cope of like, um, well, like, I
actually just don't want to see them in
a worse place, but I'm going to sue them
for all they're worth, and I just want
them to be happy, maybe, but I also am
hinting at sending somebody to beat them
up. And like, just dude, go one way or
the other. Like, you're not like you're
already doing the worst thing. If you
were like saying, "Okay, you you walk up
to a threshold and you want to walk back
from it." I understand, but you're
already doing the worst thing. You are
already threatening to sue him. You're
already threatening to ruin his life to
to take his financial security away.
You understand that? Like anything you
could say is less bad than that? Like
literally, you could go live and you
could leak like you could leak some
terrible childhood trauma in this guy
and that would be less bad than trying
to destroy his financial security.
You're already doing the worst thing.
And then you're like, "Well, I don't
want to joke about like somebody hitting
him." No, joke about somebody hitting
him. Don't sue him.
That's actually long-term life ruining.
And it's only it's only like total
psychopaths like this in the internet
who have enough money to sue all the
people they want that would ever think
this way. Everybody else has skin in the
game. They've got stake, right? They've
got a stake in and they don't want to
lose it. It's It's so psychotic, man.
It's just embarrassing.
>> I need to pull the plug. I mean,
>> yes. Yes. Suing Idubbbz is actually
worse than a CPS call. I totally agree
with that. A CPS call is really bad.
Would never endorse it. A CP a CPS call
is way over the line for online. Suing
him over a over a joke that he leaves up
on stream, even if it's defamatory. It's
I'm sorry that is worse. You are trying
to destroy this guy's life. You
a CPS call is some plausible good reason
to do it. You're just crashing out on
Idubbbz cuz he called you a [__] gonna
be in. You think she's not gonna pull
the plug if you're in a close to
vegetative state?
>> She's pulling the plug.
>> Exactly. You think she's not pulling
that plug?
>> So many options there. She's like,
>> you might even you might even just be in
a coma and they'll be like, there's a
good chance he'll be back in a week.
>> She's like, pull the plug. I I hate to
see him like this. It's
>> like a million-dollar baby.
>> That's sad movie. That's a spoiler,
dude. Come on.
>> Sorry. Button it.
>> It is so crazy.
>> Like, you know what I mean?
Bro,
>> uh, it's so up just the whole idea of
like I'm gonna these guys, they've got
like a house there. They've got a what
was the joke about like we we're going
to take his house in Portland or
something.
It's just so psycho. It's just totally
psycho.
>> I wouldn't pull the plug. I wouldn't.
That's why it's such a shame that you
threw our friendship away. I would have
paid to keep you on life support
even when the the waves in your brain
had ceased to flow. But there was a
there's still a murmur in your heart. A
beat, a pulse. Would have kept it alive.
Not her. In fact, do we
>> I think he'd be locked to a 24-hour
stream from his hospital bed with TTS in
a donation goal playing the content cop
theme every $100.
>> Okay.
>> Even know when she got
>> I don't know. Do I cope about Nicholas
ever having been funny? Cuz that I don't
know what that's supposed to be. But
okay. Insurance.
>> Did she leap the mole? Little fisherman
fan. Okay. People saying Lee the Mole or
something about AB tapes. You you guys
aren't going to have any sort of effect
on me. All right. No effect.
>> What?
>> I think he's talking about this this
leaked Discord. Snark Discord. I don't
know what else cuz they say
>> is he the mole? There was a mole in
there.
>> I don't think so. It's just because he
he said a while ago in the office.
>> Oh, Ethan. Oh, you just you're so obsess
he's so obsessed with it already. Just
the idea. Oh, buddy.
Oh, no. Oh, no. He's so obsessed with
the idea of this Discord already. No,
there's a literal mole in their house.
There's a literal mole in their house.
Oh, it's all about the Discord. Idups is
in the Discord and a song's in the
Discord. Pass messages to the Discord. I
see it all. I see it all.
We're going to get them. We're going to
get them. Nobody can possibly dislike me
this much. Nobody can possibly It's all
because Hassan and items are telling
them to. And I can prove it. I'll prove
it to you guys. You guys hear me? I'll
prove it. I'll be vindicated. I'll be
vindicated in the end. I can prove it.
And you know I can prove it. And that's
why you're scared. And that's why you're
telling me to move on. That's why you're
telling me to move on with my life that
I'm being obsessed. But you're actually
just trying to trick me because all of
you really want you really want Adams to
get away with this. You want Hassan to
get away with it? Cuz Dan, you used to
like Hassan. Remember when we did
leftovers, Dan? And you liked Hassan?
You laughed at his jokes, but you can't
laugh at my jokes now, Dad. Really?
Really? Really? Sorry, I got a little
too into the character listening.
>> They were saying leak to a pig.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah. You know how I know that that he
doesn't have a mole? Not that I need any
anything at all. Seemed pretty surprised
when he got that cease and assist.
Everybody in this office knew exactly
what I was doing. Every single one of
them. Every one of them.
>> So, your mole dropped the ball on that
one, buddy.
>> Right.
>> The most growth. M growth possibilities
are an interesting one. That might
actually be a battle I would lose.
>> See, he just said he has small.
>> And Nissa already said that.
>> True.
>> Very, very powerful. Very mighty
powerful in the short period of time.
I'm not talking about the the growth
I've had over the past 10 years because
that is colossal. Uh I mean I'm being
extremely serious when I say those
things. It's not because I do realize a
lot of this is unfortunately I don't
think it should be content. I don't
think these things should be broadcasted
on the internet, especially if you're
serious about it. Um, what
>> I mean this is about this is about my
children.
>> No, it's not. Oh, dude. Come on, man.
>> Don't make it about your Don't use your
kids, bro. And you you say Hassan uses
kids as a shield. Holy, man.
Holy.
Are you serious? This is about my kids.
This is about my kid. Dude, your kids
don't know anything about this. And you
are, by the way, if you thought that
people with nothing to lose, total
losers on the internet who were calling
in anonymous to your house, if you
thought that you're going to scare them
away by doxing some people or attacking
some people, you thought any of that was
going to happen, that's you're going to
get the opposite. As every single person
on the internet has found out every
single time, you can't threaten people
away from you on the internet about like
this. You you just can't do it. You can
identify other targets and make them
hurt for covering it if you want.
I you can do that. You're going to
you're going to 10x your hate every
single time you do it. So, if you want
to if you want to go down that trail and
you want to totally destroy yourself,
feel free to. The the true path to
happiness for your kids is to stop
getting so invested in these fights.
Just do your show. Stay away from Enan
and Issa. Stay away from your old friend
group. Move on with your life and be
happy. That's how you could be. That's
what would be good for you and your
kids. any other any other choice, any
other course of action is going to
continuously get you into drama,
continuously get you into fights, and
you're basically putting winning an
internet beef with Idubbbz, Casey, Tron,
Froggen, Denims above the well-being of
everyone around you. That's what you're
trying to do. Yeah. I mean, that's what
he's trying to do. It's sad. And I'm not
going to tell you you can't. You can do
that. It's more content for everybody on
the internet. I guess kind of, but
>> people forget. But when this whole thing
started, when CPS came to my house, came
on the show the same day.
>> You were planning to sue these people
before CPS came to your house, you lying
duplicitous worm.
>> Day and I told everybody the rules of
enga engagement have changed. The line
has moved. The barriers are gone. That
was a year ago. It's taken me time,
right, to to for all my plans to
culminate and stuff. But I meant that
these people went after my children and
and maybe you didn't make the call, Ian,
but you [__] love the people that did
you.
>> So you basically know he's not
responsible for the call. He doesn't
love those people. Nobody loves those
people. That call, by the way, basically
everybody who doesn't like Ethan and
talks about him on the internet will
agree that that calls beyond the pale.
You should not make that call, right?
They're they basically all be like,
"Yeah, it's probably a little too far."
There are some people, but it's probably
too far.
But here's the thing. It's like
it's over the line. But there is some
person there are some there's some group
of people who are not crazy who could
make that call based on the you said.
And so while I would bet on a crazy
person having done it who's probably
like an insane person who hates you,
like somebody who spends a ton of time
on the internet or something, right? I
would bet on that. It's not for sure.
And you put your family at risk with the
way you talked and you'll never take
responsibility for it.
problem saying like maybe it was needed.
I don't know. Your fans seemed worried
when nobody was worried and he shows
comments kaka house. Clearly they're
joking.
>> Klein poo poo house. So this is this is
this is and has always been about my
children.
>> Oh that's a total lie.
>> You forgot because it's been so long,
right? You think
>> you're actually such a disgusting
fantastic [__] Dude, are you serious?
This has always been about my children.
It's about your ego. You're just a piece
of It's always been about your ego. It
was never about what's best for your
kids. You're There's a real chance your
kids know don't remember this. You know
what's going to You know what's going to
crystallize that into a memory? You
constantly yapping about it to
everybody. You constantly spiraling in
your grievance about it. There's a
chance your kids could have moved on
from this and never thought about it
again. You are crystallizing it for them
because you are an egotistical, whiny.
And again, I will I'll do the throat
clear.
Nobody should have done that. Obviously,
touching the poop is bad. If somebody
did that, hypothetically, if somebody
did that, which I would bet on that
being the most probable explanation,
that's really, really bad. I never would
want anybody in my audience to do
something like that. I wouldn't want
anyone in any adjacent audience to do
something like that. But holy, man, it's
you could have moved on and you've made
it your entire personality for the past
year. It's the only thing you talk
about, man.
>> A silly game for content or something.
It's It's not for me. I haven't
forgotten.
>> You think I forgot that CPS came to my
house and interviewed my children?
>> Everybody else forgets, bro.
>> I I have not forgotten.
>> Like, if I'm being overly charitable to
him, I can see thinking your family's
being attached, causing you to spazz and
do the wrong thing, but then to sustain
the wrong thing and double and triple
and quadruple down on it. Yeah, exactly.
Like, if he just freaked out and filed
those lawsuits and then been like, "You
know what? That would have been, man, I
could have been an Ethan Klein fan if he
if he'd like filed those lawsuits and
gone, "Oh, you know what? This is too
much. I got a little too into this. I'm
actually back it off. I'm going to move
on. I'm going to try to do better
things,
right? I could I could totally do that."
But I have
>> I could be I could be an Ethan Klein fan
if he had done that. If he just
identified pretty quickly that, hey,
this was a mistake. I think the Rubicon
is the Casey Trot apology where he just
like transparently didn't give a about
the law or his copyright. He just wanted
to humiliate Casey Tron. He just wanted
to like extract clout from that
situation. As soon as that became clear,
it wasn't about punishing her. By the
way, if it was about your kids, if it
was about creating like this this idea
that you were with and it was about your
kids and you need to [__] you need to
some people up to show you couldn't be
attacked, you would have bankrupted
Caseyron. That's just facts, buddy. But
it wasn't about that. You wanted
humiliation.
It was actually showing I will destroy
you if you come after my kids. You would
have taken that opportunity and
bankrupted her, but you didn't cuz you
wanted to. You didn't want to seem like
a piece of [__] to everybody around you.
This is you waffling again. You're not
that guy. And you'll never be happy
trying to pretend that you are that guy.
You're like a nerdy guy. You're not like
this this gigachad in high school who
didn't get stuffed in lockers. You're
the nerdy kid who got stuffed in lockers
and became artistic and then eventually
made a YouTube channel. All right. Stop
trying to like become somebody you're
not. You're not You're spiritually just
not that guy, man. It's just it's rough
to watch cuz he's he has he has
everything he needs to be happy in the
world and he won't just walk away and
take it and have it and just be happy.
It's so sad, man.
>> And just like I promised, right? Just
like I promised then. I'm literally just
following through in my promises that I
made back then. It's all
>> Well, I'm totally safe then cuz when
that happened, I was totally on Ethan
Klein's side. I was like, "Oh, this is
disgusting. Oh, this is horrible. Oh,
it's up that they Dude, that's like
worse than a swatting. It's worse than a
swatting this the calling CPS. That's
worse than a swatting. Like I was
totally on his side. He's burned all
goodwill with me in the past year, man.
I had some goodwill left. I've got
nothing left now. All I'm doing.
>> I think the whole thing is extremely
silly. Uh so I would be fine.
>> And also, listen, if you didn't want to
get sued or deal with this, don't put a
statement on your screen that says I my
children. I mean, that's not rocket
science, is it? It's pretty basic
decency.
>> Wouldn't basic decency to be like to do
something to the guy who's calling you a
kids.
>> It's not.
>> If uh it not
>> or you try to is the lesson there for
your kids that when they go back and
watch your content that this guy stepped
back to you, you got slapped and so you
let him say you your kids. Is that the
lesson you're you're leaving in history
now? You got slapped by Destiny and then
you walked away and he knew he you so he
started talking about how you're a your
kids. I would never say that about you
but Destiny did and you totally took it
because you are a [__] You are his
not you know with just uh what do you
call that? What do they call it? I think
I don't think there's an official name
for it. Financial torture. I think it's
it's an attempt of doing a financial
torture in my opinion. In my opinion
>> it's called accountability. Okay. When
people push you and repeatedly push you
and do things and you respond, you try
to use your words to respond, makes it
worse. They take it out of context. They
push, they push, they push, they make it
worse. They send CPS. They send skulls.
That's it. They make these silly [__]
snark groups.
>> Dude, um, just I do want to
They make these stupid snark groups. I
liked Ethan Klein. I was fine with Ethan
Klein.
I was on his side when the CPS call was
made and he burned all goodwill with me.
So if you're if this is about your kids,
Ethan, and anybody who is it's just
about your kids and CPS, know that back
then I was on your side and your actions
since then have turned me entirely
against you. I think you were a totally
you're a massively harmful, total piece
of you're a dirt bag and you need to you
need to honestly be held accountable
too, right? Just like you're trying to
hold items accountable, you're you need
to be held accountable, too. Okay.
>> Why should denims be allowed to just
steal my content wantingly?
This is accountability.
This is not financial torture. This is
the system. I'm using the system in the
only way that I can. I'm sorry that the
system is up and that you don't like the
results, the ramifications for your
actions, but this is not
this is not torture. This is this is
consequences of your guys' direct
action. Uh-huh. I didn't have to.
>> Why does he even Why would you even
argue that those would be mutually
exclusive? They're just obviously not
mutually exclusive at all. It's just
weird to even pretend that you think
that.
>> Like, it's just an obvious lie.
>> Any of you guys. And frankly, I would
love to not be in any lawsuits, right?
>> You know, you have the power not to do
that, right?
>> Um, so listen, I'm not going to say if
I'm suing him or not. I'm going to deal
with all this stuff.
>> Yeah, we we couldn't guess. We couldn't
say. No, I can't say if I'm suing him or
not, guys. No, you know what? No. No,
no, no, no, no.
>> Behind the scenes and I I'm out. I'm
done talking about them. I wish them all
the best. I mean,
>> it's so sad that like it's so
transparently about his ego. Again, he
makes the argument that he has to do all
of these things because these people
went after his kids. But then when he
gets a chance to actually hurt one of
these people, these people that he
claims went after his kids, he totally
takes a knee and lets them apologize.
Now, I think that's the better outcome
for Casey Tron. But if it was really not
about his ego, if it wasn't about
internet beefs and petty shallow petty
shallow like jokes that people told that
hurt his ego, if it was about really
just his kids and protecting his kids
and setting a precedent, he would have
bankrupted Caseyron, right? He would
have he would have stood on business
here and said, "Yes, I am suing Idubbbz
because it's about my kids." But
instead, because Nicholas Doro says,
"No, no, no, no, don't do that, Ethan.
You can't do that." Now he's like, "Oh,
I can't say if I'm suing him now. I
can't even say. No, I can't even say.
It's never been about your kids. It's
just about your ego. Stop.
Come on, man.
>> In a sense, in like the proverbial
sense.
>> Listen, sometimes the best path forward
take includes steps backwards. And me
wishing them the best is maybe them
doing the right thing behind the scenes.
>> In a real job,
>> they make a hell of a lot more money.
Yeah. But I'm I'm out. And uh good luck
to them and all that. and uh everything
I do is just going to be uh I by the way
I never even planned to really even talk
about the lawsuit with them or the cease
and assist. I only brought it up because
he started like dancing around like he
was some paragon of principles and stuff
and I was like no you're not. Also I
just want to give a shout out to my
friend the pope Nicholas Dioro who he's
having a hard time uh rationalizing my
decision and that's fine. Listen, I like
Nick. He's the pope. You can't question
the pope. Don't make me Don't make me
blow that gray smoke. I'm just kidding.
I was just I was just trying to play the
analogy. Excuse me. He's having a hard
time uh rationalizing my decision. And
that's fine.
>> Mr. Nicholas Dioro can't rationalize
Ethan Clyde's decision-m.
>> Listen, I like Nick. Don't make me don't
make me blow that gray smoke. I'm just
kidding. I was just I was trying to play
the analogy.
Excuse me. No, I completely don't mind
him thinking this is stupid or petty or
that he disagrees, but he says again
can't for the life of me fathom why it
would be a flex. This he said it's just
two poor losers in Canada over them
showing a comment completely different
person said without pursuing destiny
and
um I've seen a few people that I like
echoing this sentiment. So that's why I
thought I'll just respond to it and
with love, right? Just to to to explain
myself. I mean, I I've explained like
the technical aspect of it that one,
Destiny lives in America. Two, he he
soon after stated he doesn't believe it.
Right? So those are two disqualifying
facts. But I it's like I said, I said
this a year ago or plus when it started.
I'm just following through on my
promises, man. It's not a flex. I'm not
doing it to flex. I'm not doing it to be
>> You've been doing it to flex the whole
time.
>> Cool. I'm not doing it.
>> Stop making it about good. Makes me look
good or cool. I probably makes me look
unhinged, right? To the general public.
I probably look like a crazy person
that's suing everybody. And I
>> You have looked like a crazy person
that's suing everybody since you started
suing people. Yeah,
>> I understand that. I don't want to be
that guy.
>> You are that guy. You do want to be that
guy. If you understand that and you do
it anyway, then you want to be that guy,
right?
>> I don't want to be that guy for this
show. I don't want to be that guy for
this person, for people that love me. I
don't want to be wrapped up in this
stuff. But
listen, people came after my
>> I understand perfectly that everybody
sees me as a crazy person suing
everyone.
And I don't want to be that guy, but I'm
going to keep suing people. Yeah, you're
just there's something broken here. You
do want to be that guy. children and I
said the rules changed and they did
change and they haven't gone back to how
they used to be just because it's been a
year just because people forgot about it
or people
the impact of it is lessened on them cuz
it's not lessened on me and Ela it's not
lessened on me and my wife we live in
the same house same children so
um that
yeah Ian and Nissa they've met my
children I mean it's personal these
people have into my house. They they've
met my children.
And then for them to claim
on a huge platform that it's good that
CPS came to investigate
the tip the that my children were eating
dog [__] off the floor.
And by the way, let's remember in his
initial content cop, he conveniently
ignored
Yeah, we've heard this whole spiel
before, man. I don't know why you just
Does the audience still like this? They
just need to hear the recounting of how
CPS was called every single time. CPS,
CPS, CPS. Skulls, skulls, skulls,
skulls. Dude, why do you think people
have Discords with skulls as the avatar
that have CPS written across the
forehead? Why the do you think it's
because you are obsessed with